with just weeks ago before the film's
release a second trailer for Halloween
has arrived to scare us all set 40 years
after Michael Myers first terrorized the
town of Haddonfield the new film will
ignore every one of the series sequels
that means no Colts those psychic
visions and none of the mythology that
made Michael a brother to Jamie Lee
Curtis 'as Laurie Strode despite this
acting of the Canon the new movie was
made in cooperation with John Carpenter
the Original Movies director co-writer
and composer so Halloween isn't totally
rejecting its franchise instead its
reinterpreting it in an exciting way the
new trailer is packed of interesting
details and references that you might
not have seen at first glance let's
shine a light on the little things you
might have missed close encounter from
the marketing it's clear the new
Halloween is getting back to the series
roots the trailers first shot follows
two kids trick-or-treating trying to
decide which house to plunder for candy
next they literally run into a tall
rigid figure in a black jumpsuit who
barely reacts to them the kids scurry
away and Michael goes on about his
murderous business the shop mirrors a
daytime scene from the 1978 film when
one of the boys bullying Tommy Doyle
runs away from school only to almost
plow into Michael it's a reference to
the original that also serves to deepen
our understanding of Michael even if he
bump right into him nothing bothers this
killing machine PACA lantern the
jack-o'-lantern is synonymous with
Halloween both the holiday and the
original film they can be seen
everywhere as Michael stalks the streets
of Haddonfield but they're more than
just set dressing they also seem to give
Michael some ideas at one point in the
trailer a car door opens to reveal a
crude jack-o'-lantern made from a flayed
human face and what appears to be a dead
cop slab illuminated from the inside by
a flashlight why Michael would stop in
the middle of his killing spree for some
morbid arts-and-crafts is a mystery but
you can't deny it's an amazing gore
moment if they put that in the trailer
we can't wait to see what's in the movie
silver shamrock the third Halloween
movie season of the which is the only
entry in the series not to feature
Michael Myers a standalone story about
haunted novelty masks the movie was a
failed effort to turn the Halloween
series into an anthology but despite
existing outside of my
called story the three call still gets a
shout-out in this trailer as Laurie runs
around like a mad woman waving a gun and
shouting people off the streets we see
three children run by wearing three
different masks of which a skeleton and
a jack-o'-lantern these three masks are
recognizable as the ones made by
Halloween three silver shamrock company
cursed objects that killed the people
wearing them so while most of the
continuity may be done for silver
shamrock still lives on you'll never get
that theme song out of your head
[Music]
Castle doctrine the new films Lauria
spends her adult life preparing for the
return of Michael Myers
but despite to that occasion to
survivalism she also managed to have a
family in the new trailer she chastises
her daughter Karen for being lacs about
security which Karen dismisses she even
seems to think her mom is crazy you need
help as the trailer demonstrates Laurie
really needs their help we've already
seen her out in the woods practicing her
target shooting and keeping an
underground bunker stocked with supplies
this trailer reveals more of her in case
of Michael set up including a hidden gun
cabinet LED lights on her roof and the
panic room door that slams down as she
prepares for a confrontation she's been
waiting for this fight for years and
while she seems capable of getting
vengeance
hopefully Michael doesn't take her with
him when he goes core work one of the
most memorable moments in the original
Halloween occurs as Laurie sits
exhausted with Michael's seemingly dead
on the floor behind her it's a tension
relieving moment until Michael suddenly
bolts a bright looking completely
unharmed it's not a corny jump scare
either he sits up in silence moving in a
completely stiff frightening Lee in
natural way he doesn't move like a man
sporting fresh stab wounds the trailer
shows a new movie bringing bat that
maneuver with Michael doing the iconic
set up once again after Laurie knocks
him down some stairs even after 40 years
Michael's remarkable core strength is
apparently still intact his abs must be
incredible
[Music]